says this morning that retired Pope  Benedict's health is worsening and Pope  Francis is asking the faithful to pray  for him the pope Emeritus is 95 years  old he's been retired since 2013 when he  became the first leader of the Roman  Catholic Church to resign in nearly 600  years Benedict said at the time that his  declining physical and mental health  made it necessary for him to step down  the last time he was seen in public was  four weeks ago receiving an award this  morning Pope Francis told visitors at  his Wednesday audience that Benedict is  quote very sick a spokesperson says  Francis visited the pope Emeritus  afterward